yup
the bounce the bounce of striking that
gives me a kick that i can follow
so i redirect it onto his left
he's very quick because he sees that
bounce and he moves his hand away
and then again
so this is for the people who want the
technical
did i win oh i don't know i was too busy
so if you're too busy and you end up at
the end and you think i enjoyed that or
you feel a bit claustrophobic he was a
little bit he was coming to me a bit
close what's it telling you don't do it
again make it move more
don't get stuck in that rut
okay
so for you sir dan's and above
there's a very important point that you
need to understand
this is technically
here
don't do that and leave it outside his
body
do that and bring it back
so that you make sure that
you've got him under control he's got to
go around your can then
all right so that's the big point for
you to know
okay
one more
breathe relax
there's a lot of detail in the secondary
faction
i know
exactly through so many years
of how much i need to move a lot of you
are doing this
there's no way i can reach his wrist
without now becoming the attacker
so i'm going to work out my knees about
what
eight inches so i need to move ten
inches if he's cut deep
if he's cut deep i know i've got
so without looking at my knee just
through years and years of practice you
get to know where your measurement is
if you can do that then you can work out
how to cut the wrist
and it reaches his wrist i didn't have
to do anymore
i don't have to go
right
the minute i do that i'm becoming the
attacker
i said zach you know's gone finished
he doesn't like that he pulls his wrist
back
he now has to go around the side to get
me
as he does that go back again as he does
that
i don't think of the saw this end but i
touch
i connect there so i just lift that up
and i just
roll back
as if he's
you know playing paul or
snooker that action
is what i'm feeling
so from here to here
to
there all i've got to do is keep my
belly
sort of heavy
and transmit it through there
this is for the people who want the
technical
this is the first uh ken how i say
i can't reach the hand
and that's where it should be
it's here you're pressing
down
but you're pressing
on the whole length of your ken it's not
just
not just parts
the whole length of the ken
that second cabin tattoo first weapons
uh
variation yuck
and you just think everything parallel
right down then
the next one's interesting
you press it on their stomach
like that
and so you don't go wrong and turn the
wrong way you just keep pushing
and pushing and pushing and pushing and
pushing
and it will turn it into exactly where
it needs to be
those who think that you can get high
remember you're going to chase partners
again
so it's always going to be difficult
because you've got someone new to blend
to
so the challenge today really is in that
as well
yup
it doesn't actually hit the chest
but for you to get the direction i'd
like you to put it on there and keep
pushing it so that it
it shows you where it needs to go
and you cut the back of their head they
say the shoulder i don't care what it is
as long as you end up in the right place
at
it's very simple
it's not so simple is it
i bend as quick as i can i press it down
he then comes here
if i do this
he's both i can't see him
but he's got all this time now i've just
seen me
the other question i was asked was
do i step with the other leg no i step
with this same leg
a big step
and then i do
it's called hapogiri it's
it comes from
it comes from nigeria
he's going to see me this is with the
back to back one he's going to see me
he's going to turn
and
usually we end up doing that when we're
doing tattoos don't we we oh fine i only
just made it
so you get
here
and oh i'll do it this side
your end up so you don't really know
where you're going
the closer i get to him
hard you you should all know this they
can't punch you if you're that close
so watch where i go this isn't the
second kim attack somehow
all right
i put myself in the middle and show you
what i put myself in the middle
because i need him to have a target
now i vanish
so where is that in this
i have to leave
i could be here
so that
he can see me
i mustn't not let him see me
until
it starts to cut and then i i know it's
safe to go
so there is a lot in there
yuck
ah
if you're not at this angle
if you're around here that's too far
you should be cutting
this is what you do without you knowing
it you actually
almost do what he does so you see the
distance between me and his chest
so when you go to then put it on his
chest
it's a really big jump you go
cool i had a really big jump to get
around the back there
and it's because
i've seen you know when you see these
illusionists they
they'll
make a
jumper jumping jet
vanish
we go it was out there it's an illusion
i still haven't worked it out
so here
here
this tip when he lifts i actually don't
take off i actually go underneath him
so when he releases me
i actually
go to him and that never comes back that
way again that way
he does the bigger jump
and i do a small jump
because i don't have to go through the
effort right
so again it's a it's a bit lift lifted
it's a bit like a
if you go like that
already
i've got am i going to get from here to
behind him because i've stopped him i've
slowed him up so he'll just do a perhaps
a half step or something he won't do a
big step
so my attempt he wasn't made
so
you can only do this by repetition
overnight what you want to do is you
want to get your best mate if you can or
your worst enemy somebody and just do it
and do it and do it and do it
but then when you've done it lots and
lots of times and video yourself and
then look at all the things you've done
wrong